hey eric any tricks for white in london
versus kings indian
oh yeah just just watch my games i like
to play knight c3
on move three yeah i mean
there's a few ways you can play london
against king's indian
um i assume you're you're referring to
this position
uh what i like to do is knight c3 which
is
it's not like a traditional london setup
because you're going for e4
but if black allows this you do you do
this stuff and then
attack on the king side if black
prevents e4
then you can do this and go for the
h-pawn push
there's a line where opinion on the
mexican defense
could you try one game huge mexico city
oh la hola
como estas
yeah if you if you go for if you get
this position where you sack the
exchange
um you're down material but you're
you're crushing like stockfish will give
plus
stockfish will just crash because you're
you're so you're so good here
um but for i know there's some london
players that just like to stick with
their usual
like e3 etc so i can show
one just quick trick where you you could
you do your typical london setup
um but don't don't play bishop d3 your
bishop has no purpose here when black
has pawns on h7 and g6
so play bishop e2 let's say black plays
king's indian
um then don't play knight d2 the best
way to develop here is to play c4
and knight c3 not only because it's more
active but there's also
uh some tricks involved actually
you know what play h3 first just so if
knight h5 you save your bishop
you could also play h3 earlier but then
still go for c4
and then there's a trap here uh if we
look on the chess
like this is a pretty common position
because it's just black doing the main
king's indian setup
obviously black wants to play e5 e5 is
the most played move
by far 5205 games
um
just checking rookie yeah rookie is also
like most common
so basically when black plays rook e8 e5
is lightly coming
and you let black play e5 because in
this position you're winning a pawn
i'll just go ahead and show it uh you
just take
takes and even though black has two
defenders
you can get a way of taking because of
the alignment on the d-file
and that's one of the reasons why you
don't play knight d2 you leave the
possibility open for this x-ray vision
because after takes you then take the
rook is overworked and then you win a
pawn
so that's just a quick trap winning a
pawn
in the london against king's indian
um maybe
maybe i'll turn this into a quick
youtube video because i get this
question every so often of like how to
play the london against the king's
indian
and then that will make my life easier i
can just direct people to
whatever this three or four minutes
explanation
and this is just kind of a quick start
hopefully give some people some some
ideas
some options so hello to youtube
if you wanna learn more you can
subscribe you can follow on twitch
you can join twitch and ask questions
and